You wouldn't get it...
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my video for the Joker
deleted scene an alternate ending and
obviously a lot of questions about
what's going on with the Joker as a
character during the new Batman movies
that are being made with Robert
Pattinson and Matt Reeves there's a
whole bunch of Easter eggs so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get everything will actually do a
giveaway for the Joker movie on blu-ray
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the movie on the video so
we'll start by talking about the Joker
alternate ending and deleted scene then
I'll talk about the Batman movie and
what's going on with the Joker character
during the new trilogy the deleted scene
is a big change to the ending and a big
change to the version of the Batman
mythos that we got during the movie
because the one that we got even though
there are a couple minor changes is
pretty close to a comic book accurate
version of his origin story they just
kind of leave it at that moment with him
in the alleyway but in that version one
of the rioting men in the clown masks
hears Joker's broadcast from Murray
studio is it inspired by his words and
he just happens to be standing outside
the movie theater that Thomas Martha and
Bruce Wayne just exited follows them
into the alleyway and gives us our
expectedly
mostly comic-book accurate version of a
Batman origin story where he guns down
Thomas and Martha Wayne ripping off the
pearls which is also right off the comic
book page and leaving Bruce sitting
there in shock with their bodies around
him you also probably noticed a bunch of
Batman Easter eggs as they're exiting
the theatre to meta Easter eggs for the
Joker character as well because this is
meant to be early 80s era Gotham and
they actually date it because of the
movies that are being released as you
see on the walls and the posters
Excalibur is just a really awesome
old-school King Arthur movie if you've
never seen it I would recommend it Zorro
the gay blade is just a comedy version
of the classic Zorro story and then the
comedy film Arthur all three of those
were released in 1981 so you say the
Joker movie happened in 1981 the one
minor changed that they made to the
classic comic book Batman origin story
is the actual movie that they were
seeing at the theater before they were
gunned down in the original version of
the origin story it was the 1940 Mark of
Zorro movie because adult Batman was
created in the comics in 1939 so that
just happened to be the most recent
version of Zorro that was released
publicly they just changed that to this
version of Zorro to be period specific
to 1981 I also kind of feel like they
included the Arthur or comedy movie
because it would have been playing
this time and his name is Arthur Fleck
during the movie the alternate version
of this ending would have been
dramatically different in a much bigger
change to the Batman origin story in the
deleted scene when Joker is in the white
clothes at arkham asylum talking to his
therapist and starts laughing saying I
was thinking of a joke
you wouldn't understand it we would have
flashback to the same scene of Thomas
and Martha Wayne dying but instead of
Joe Chill being the one in the clown
mask to kill them it would have been
Joker himself killing the Wayne's
then as he turns to walk away Bruce
Wayne starts crying out in shock
Joker pauses Abid shrugs turns around
kills Bruce Wayne too then walks away it
would have definitively answered what
their take on the Batman character was
like no there's not going to be a Batman in
this universe obviously because that
scene didn't make it into the final cut
of the movie it's not canon anymore and
you could still assume that someday
there will be a Batman running around
this version of Gotham but you probably
understand why they chose to get rid of
that scene it sounds horrifying and just
in favor of something a little more
toned down a little more comic-book
accurate and way more ambiguous just to
give the audience a chance to take their
own interpretation if you were confused
about what was going on at the end of
the movie and what this symbolism meant
with him walking down the hallway so the
scene of Joker talking to the therapist
was supposed to be happening after a
short time jump where he was eventually
captured by the police brought to Arkham
Asylum and this person is just
evaluating his mental state the very end
scene with the jump cut to him walking
down the hallway as the music's playing
leaving the footprints is meant to imply
that he killed the therapist is in the
process of escaping Arkham Asylum and
will go on to become the comic book
Joker yes since the movie has won all
those Awards Joaquin Phoenix just won
Best Actor for Oscar well deserved
congratulations to him he had a great
speech there has been real talk of them
doing a joker sequel eventually but
there's been no talk of what that would
be what time period it would take place
during I'll do more videos for it if
they make some more official
announcements if they really are going to
do a sequel I think one of the best
characters they could go for if they
want to do something in the DC black
label universe that's not connected to
any of the other Batman or Justice
League films The Riddler would be a
great character to do a spin like you
did on the Joker with Joaquin Phoenix
Tom King just did a big story about the
war of jokes and riddles it was all
about them battling
the Riddler in the Joker over who got
the honor of killing Batman it was funny
how they almost didn't even care about
Batman while this was going on they were
so fixated on each other so it was
really like this big turf war that they
had which I think you could totally do
on the lesser scale that these DC black
labels seem to be like them spending
less than a hundred million dollars to
make it r-rated but because they just
released that new Batman teaser with the
first look at Robert Pattinson 'he's
batman in the new bat suit everyone is
wondering what are they going to do with
his most iconic villain in the new
Batman trilogy I've seen a lot of you
also asking would Joaquin Phoenix the
Joker ever crossover with the new Batman
movies if the timeline makes sense well
when they were making the Joker movie
Todd Phillips was hyping up his DC black
label like this is meant to be separate
I'm doing my own thing I don't want to
have to pay attention to what those
other people are doing with the other DC
and Justice League characters doing it
that way is also part of how he sold
them on doing a rated-r version of the
character because you couldn't really do
a rated-r Joker trying to cross it over
with the pg-13 movies he would have to
tone it way way down when people
specifically asked Todd Phillips about
crossing over with the Robert Pattinson
Batman movies he said definitely not at
least right now
but when you think of this from Matt
Reeves perspective because he's making a
Batman movie so he has controlled pretty
much any character that he wants to use
from Batman's rogues gallery right now
Joker is confirmed to not be in the new
Batman movie that they're filming right
now as we speak but eventually they're
going to make their way through all of
Batman's biggest most iconic rogues
gallery of villains through the other
films in the trilogy you can still get
away with not doing Joker in the second
movie in the next two to three years
because you still have a ton of awesome
classic villains that aren't going to be in
the first movie like Clayface mr. freeze
two-face so early prediction Matt Reeves
doesn't try to use a version of the
Joker until the third Robert Pattinson
Batman movie assuming that they do get
through a new trilogy and everything
goes well that would be minimum 5 to 6
years before that could even happen so
by that time they'll be fine to recast a
new version of the Joker character if
they want to exist within the continuity
of those new Batman movies so as of
right now I don't think there's any
plans to crossover Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker with any of the other DC movies if
he does Joker 2 it'll be its own thing
off by itself
kind of the way they're pitching the new
Batman movies that take place off in
their own little bubble of continuity
because it's said during a different
time period so he hasn't met Aquaman yet
he hasn't met Wonder Woman Superman any
of those other characters so you don't
really have to worry about him crossing
over with the other Justice League films
anytime soon
I realized DC's continuity sounds like
it's kind of a mess right now because
birds of prey is connected to the first
Suicide Squad film but James Gunn is
getting ready to release a new Suicide
Squad movie which is kind of a reboot of
the franchise then you have the Aquaman
sequel which is still technically
connected to Justice League you have
Wonder Woman 1984 which is set during
the past so don't worry about it too
much right now just on a case by case
movie by movie basis I will explain the
timeline and what's connected what's not
connected they actually just dropped a
bunch of new previews for Wonder Woman
1984 and it seems like we got our first
look for what cheetah actually looks
like during that movie so I might do a
breakdown of that sometime soon but
everyone let me know in the comments
what do you want them to do with the
Joker character in the new Robert
Pattinson Batman movies do you want them
to recast a different version of the
character or do you hope that they just
skip the Joker altogether and they never
do him again inside the proper Pattinson
movies everyone click here to rewatch
that new Batman teaser trailer and click
here for my brand new Avengers infinity
Saga deleted scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
This is the way.